Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on here?
This is Rob and we are back with Knoll.
We're back with King and black number one. Now here's the thing.
This is a one-shot.
So the King and black event is very much like swords of X in the sense that we
get a one-shot to open it up and then we get all the tie-ins. And again,
one of the things we talked about during, during the, the, I guess,
10 of swords, and that's what you want to call it,
it's very much reminiscent of the 1990s comics, right?
Those are the guys who remember something like age of apocalypse. For example,
I think we got age of apocalypse alpha,
and then just a whole bunch of renamed comics, right?
So we'll basically just retitled all their comics for six months.
And then we got age of apocalypse Omega. That's basically what's happening here,
albeit not alpha and Omega. It's just a one-shot opening story,
but this story is amazing, right?
So if you guys are going to the comic book stores and you're buying King and
black,
make sure that you guys buy the comic that actually has the King and black cover
on it by the King of black banner.
It's the only one that ties into the King of black event.
And of course you can find reading orders all over the place and everything,
but this initially picks up with Eddie Brock.
Now here's one of the funny things about this, right?
This is where things get a little, a little wonky here. Um,
and I'm not really sure how he got from here to there.
But if you guys remember the ending of the venom story,
Eddie Brock and his son returned to earth when there were no lights here,
the sky is still bright and everything now, uh,
we'll find out why the sky went dark,
but it's one of these things that kind of looks like a bit of a continuity error
on behalf of Donnie Cates and all that.
But I don't mind because Donnie Cates is amazing.
He does not disappoint in the story. So what we ended up getting is,
is kind of like Eddie Brock, of course,
still being possessed by the venom Simeon.
This starts to realize that the King kingdom life that no,
the Symbion God is on his way there. Now he's informed the Avengers.
He's told all of them about what's going on the arrival of Noah.
You know what it means, the power he possesses and all that kind of good stuff.
So the Avengers have basically been prepping for this, right?
They've been planning for this whole thing.
So the call goes out to all the Avengers, right?
All hands on deck and Eddie Brock goes to grab Dylan. Now, once Dylan wakes up,
he begins to realize, okay, you know, he can feel that, that Knowles on his way.
And so it was time for them to basically get out of there. Now,
switching over to captain America, she hoped Carol Danvers, iron man,
the current Avengers roster,
Tony stark has basically taken some remnants of Cree and she,
our warships and then basically weaponized them, right?
Turn them into essentially debt mateable bonds, right?
Bombs that can be remote detonated from the planet earth now.
But when all of these kinds of that forces of,
of Knoll start showing up that all these different vessels start exploding,
right?
They literally start going off and Tony Stark's starts to celebrate the problem
with this is that you in turn have Eddie Brock who basically hits the iron man
and says, we killed about a hundred of them,
but like there's countless of these things showing up here, right?
It looks like millions and millions of these things showing up here,
seemingly one for everybody on earth, you would presume. So three, I'm sorry,
7 billion at the very most, if not, any number less than that,
which is still way more than 100. And he's like, you know,
we only stopped a hundred of them. Well, he can't be stopped. Now.
One other thing that I want to point out,
and it seems to only really affect Eddie at the moment is that all these bats
being destroyed seem to take a toll on him,
but it could also be because of the fact that Eddie is using his powers to
monitor everything out there. Right.
So it could just be a kind of mental strain,
but I didn't want to draw attention to that because all these bat forces start
pouring down onto the city and basically like exploding, right?
Like as they pour down,
they basically explode into their symbiont forms and literally kind of filled
the appeal, the world with like an ocean of symbionts. Right.
It's basically what it looks like,
but you actually end up having venom Eddie Brock taking his son,
Dylan to a bunker that was built for Peter Parker by a ZQ now a little bit of
explanation here. Right? And we cover all this in my video series on, uh,
Dan Slott Spiderman run. So you're welcome to check that out. You know,
especially spider verse different things like that.
But the idea is that somewhere along the line, you had a guy named Ezekiel.
And then of course,
Zico became aware of the fact that the inheritors were hunting down Spider-Man
right. All across the multi-verse.
And so this bunker was built for Peter Parker to protect him if you needed to
stay hidden. And of course, Peter was actually confined there for some time.
And I think it's ETL actually use it as a base of operations for some time.
Now a zeal is a character that I believe was introduced during J Michael's
Luzinski drawn before he wrote Spider-Man one more day,
which is one of those things where everybody loved the run until they didn't.
But you know,
that's kind of a nice little nod to like the yesteryear of Spider-Man stories,
like just old school stuff, kind of bringing, uh, being brought back. But the,
the,
the meat and potatoes here is that this bunker should protect Dylan from Knoll
and anybody else out there that's trying to get to him one,
because it's difficult to know what's there. And two,
because of the fact that it's just so well guarded,
it's just so difficult to penetrate. And so with that being the case,
Dylan actually wants to go and he kind of has this genius moment. He's like,
look, I have the same powers as no, right?
So maybe I can seize control of NOLs army, like take it away from him.
But in reality here,
and this is something that's not really voiced by Eddie Brock.
I doubt that would happen.
And the reason why is because Dylan is still relatively new to his powers,
right?
So it was like a person could just discover telepathy versus a person who's been
practicing telepathy for like 50 years. It's just,
they're far more prodigious in the use of their powers.
And so for somebody like Dylan, yes, his powers are comparable to,
to NOLs in so far as he can control symbions. But he's not as able,
he's not as capable of using his powers in the same way. No is I,
so there's a much better chance that Dylan will be defeated and possibly consume
taken over by Knoll than he would to actually win. And because of that,
Eddie says, no, like you need to stay here.
I made you a promise that I will keep you safe.
That I would do everything I could to keep you protected.
That's what we're doing from there.
You ended up having Eddie Brock who's chimed in by captain America saying plan B
and plan B is exactly what we just described. Right?
The idea that all these symbionts come pouring down. Well,
while that's happening, the Avengers are largely waiting on for right there.
They're hoping for Thor to get there. You've got Dr. Strange, you've got name,
or you've got, uh, you've got iron fist. You have all this great, big,
huge roster of people who've ever been Avengers who were here.
But Thor is also one of these guys.
We're having the ability to control the lightning and fire and lightning being
one of the weaknesses of Simeon's would go a long way towards being able to stim
this conflict. But currently Thor's not here.
What they get is something better in their stead, right? Well,
everything is popping off, right? Well, everything is popping off.
You have this,
this like speech bubble and you guys know speech bubbles usually mean telepathy.
So this voice pops in and says, iron man, captain America, please exclude it.
Please. Excuse the intrusion into your minds. This is Charles ex-Navy.
If you require backup, please stand by. My X-Men have arrived.
So you have table who shows up here, Cyclops, but I think you have Phantom X,
which is kind of weird. You've got Nightcrawler, right? You've got stormed,
Jean Gray, a full contingent of the X-Men of Roth.
And it's one of these things where Xavier's kinda like,
I know you guys are waiting on Thor,
but surely like a woman who could control the,
the thunder and the lightning would be pretty much just as good. Now,
the other part of this is that with plan B basically commencing that Eddie Brock
actually ends up going to the, uh,
going to the throne that was used by carnage and carnage use this during the
absolute carnage event to control the army that he created. And the,
the hope of Eddie Brock is that he can basically use the throne to extend his,
his reach all the way out to the symbionts here on earth that have been brought
here by Knoll, and then basically take over control of those symbionts right.
So using the throne to do what Dylan could do, but on a more grandiose scale,
right on a, on a more, on a more fine tuned scale.
The problem with this is Eddie Brock is having a wildly difficult time punching
through this kind of control that no has over a symbiotic at the same time.
Dr. Strange it's facing off as best.
He can only for us to realize just how powerful Knoll is in the sense that all
these little symbiont monster things that he has,
where all these little dragons are just punching right through.
Dr. Strange is shields. There's no, there's no way for him to stop them. Right.
But just in this, this small moment, right. When they,
when they have a chance when like Dr. Strange falls and in a Brock is like,
okay, I'm pushing through, right. I'm pushing through to the other side.
And I should be able to take over this.
80 comes to this massive realization that all hope is lost.
And the reason why when he punches through he realized is not just the dragons.
And it's not just no, no first enemies with the Celestials.
When Noah arrived here, he bought haunted to the Celestials and took them over.
No,
the Sybian God has conquered the celestial race in the
barbel university, man. That's dude, it's nuts. It's like,
all these Celestials come pouring down. And at that point, the Avengers, man,
hold on, you guys start prepping their pants. What else could I do?
Did you do at that point?
Like one of the holes open up and know comes walking out and he's just like,
so who are you guys? Right? Like, who are you supposed to be?
Are you guys like the forces here to assemble,
to take me out now while all this was going on,
they were waiting for like this big, heavy hitter to show up. Right?
It's not Thor, but they're waiting for this big, heavy hitter to show up. Right?
Finally, this heavy hitter finally arrives right now.
I was sitting there looking at this and I was like, man,
I really hope there's this who I think it is.
And it turned out to be exactly who I thought it was, right? Like,
like literally iron man chimes into captain America and says, okay,
the guy's here, right? Like he's going to be here in 10 seconds. He's here.
And he's waiting your orders. Does he have permission to engage?
And the response of captain America is permission to grant it.
Only first I find out it's the century, man, it's Rob a rental son, son, man.
It's rubber rental. This century has finally returned. And I was like, okay,
this guy comes flying through.
Boosh comes flying through punches hole through a symbions head. Right.
It's like Durham, Sunday, like punches a hole to this NBA head. Dude. He goes,
fly for no knows, like, no, like no way. Right? So like, he comes,
he's like rubber Reynolds grabs no flies up into the air. And he's like, hi,
my name's Bob. Uh, you can call me the century. This will be over in a second.
I was like, no son now, son, man, let me, let me tell you something.
He grabs a hold of Robert Reynolds. He goes to rip him in half. He's like,
Oh God, did he rip? He ripped them in half. Right. Pulls,
pulls the void right out of, right out of the century. Right.
Pulls a void out of the century. Right. And he's just like child. I am no.
Right. I'm the Lord of the abyss. God of the,
symbions the darkness inside of you. That darkness bounced to me. I am the void.
Like literally just crushes the century and one fell swoop. And it's like, well,
you go, any chance you have had is gone. Right. I guess that's, that's madness.
That's basically it like, you will all fall like the rest. Right.
I've met your Army's little ones meet mine.
So he literally just like takes control of the symbionts and pours them all over
the various superheroes.
And all the superheroes are completely conquered by the stimulus from there.
He's just like, let's get rid of this. Let's get rid of the stars out there.
So we in turn takes all those dragon forces,
merging them together and then wraps them around the world and blocks out all
the light. And it's just like. Right. So like storm,
the only one left standing, right? Like storms, like the only one left standing.
So storm goes out like that hero, man. Right? She's like, okay, look,
you just think if I'm going to fall to this weird looking guy who looks like a
failed eighties rock did like, I'm going to go out with a bang, right?
Like I'm going to go out with a bang, right.
Just summons every ounce of lightening,
she possibly can just start shocking the out of these things. Right?
It's just electric heat in these things all over the place. No,
basically summons is his symbionts again, they go wrapping up into the,
you know, into the Spire over top of where, where are right. Worst storm is.
And just like snatch her up storm is basically gone.
This one person who can control the lightening.
And that was the only real weakness of these Symbian dragon. Things is now done.
And the Savior's. So you end up having this thing worse where Eddie's like,
and he's like, okay man, here's what we're going to do. Right? No,
showed up here said, give me Brock and I will kill you as painless as possible.
Now the reality is no intends to destroy the world.
But Eddie brought stance here is no, no, no, no, no.
If I hand myself over then like maybe I could say, look,
I will hand myself over to you. My Symbion over to you. You'll be complete.
And then like, just leave earth, right? Just, just leave us alone. You know,
just let us live. It's it's a hope against hope. Right?
It's it's a terrible idea, but it's a hope against hope. Right?
So what ends up happening is you get this really touching moment, right?
Where like Eddie rocket has been, uh,
his Symbion have this conversation and the symbionts like,
look at him like you need to know, you know? And,
and it doesn't really finish a sentence,
but largely it looks like the semi was getting ready to say, like,
because of you, Eddie, I become better. Right?
Like I was lost and I was kind of villainous and I was all over the place.
I didn't really know what my greater purpose in the world was,
what it meant to be in this, in this space. But since I've been a part of you,
you've made me better and I've made you better.
We truly have become great heroes. Right.
We don't really get that much being said, but it's really cool because like,
okay, let's go meet our maker. Right.
So they basically kind of broadcast their signal, right?
Like the venom Symbion taps into NOLs Knowles forces,
which basically tells us exactly where he is. Right.
It's just firing up a flare in the sky essentially. And so no locates,
venom goes and grabs him. He snatches up Eddie Brock and brings him to him.
And then it's just like, okay, you can take me. That's fine.
But leave the world. Right. Just, just leave the world alone.
Take me and we'll call it eight. He's like, wait a minute. I remember you.
You're the one who beat my dragon. Like I thought you died. Well,
it's kind of weird, but no, I'm not here for you.
I should have specified which Brock I wanted. I don't want you. I want your son.
I want Dylan Brock. And when Eddie starts to realize what's going on,
he's just like, no, that's not going to happen. Right. Like, you know,
your fight is with us, right? Like leave my son out of it. And,
and the response of, of, no,
he rips the Symbion off of Eddie and it's just like,
I will take your Simeon away from you. I will make it mine again.
And then I'll take your son and drops Eddie Brock from the top of the sky all
the way down to the ground. Well, that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end. This was amazing.
This is a great way to start this, start this story. So I'm his man Sansa.
Does it see, this is the thing that Donnie Cates does not disappoint.
If you guys are new here to comments, explain,
make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob poor.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a like,
and I will catch you on.
We will not tolerate incoherence.
[inaudible].